have you decided out leave leave
same yeah yeah out yes
why because i remember the old days
keep going these seem like the old days
now ashby de lazusch in the midlands was
one of boris johnson's stop-offs on the
last day of campaigning
in the 2016 referendum people here voted
overwhelmingly to leave the eu
but how has the uk changed in the four
and a half years since then and with a
deal
done where do we go from here i think
the trouble was he he
he got in on i'll get brexit done
and i suppose he's got brexit done
basically
i'm glad to see it i'm glad to hear it
yeah did you vote for brexit
i did yes so is this what you were
hoping for
no no we were hoping for this to happen
a long time ago
the conversation has changed from net
migration to more about
you know holidays and trade i think we
don't really talk about net migration
anymore
is it still a concern of yours very much
i don't
i don't think anything's changed the
local mp who was beside johnson
back in 2016 would be the first to
criticize
any ground given to the eu andrew
bridgen
is optimistic about the trade agreement
and now wants
new partnerships further afield i'm
hoping
that in the next 12 months possibly
we're going to have a comprehensive free
trade free movement the ability to live
work
start a business in either canada
australia new zealand or the uk
and why is why is that better than
someone being able to start a business
in france or germany and have free
movement in those countries
because we're all parliamentary
democracies based on the same
democratic system we're we're all
relatively wealthy very wealthy
countries
so there should be no net migration so
is france and germany
the difference is that uh canada
australia new zealand
we won't be making each other's laws
political conversation has
shifted since we voted to leave the eu
for example we no longer obsess
about net migration figures even though
they remain
roughly the same we won't be concerning
ourselves with the future eu budgets or
eu laws indeed from now on if anything
goes wrong or becomes
unpopular politicians will have nowhere
to shift the blame
except of course in scotland where they
can blame westminster
and indeed within this deal nationalists
will look for levers towards
independence
nicholas sturgeon has already tweeted
that no deal will ever make up
for what brexit has taken away remaining
as one
um in the future puts us in a stronger
position
i think we'll strengthen the case of
independence unfortunately
i think it's going to give nicholas
sturgeon more of a platform to
go for independence i think it's it's
just going to boost that whole
kind of plan further after years of
dominating our politics
the boundaries of our new relationship
with the eu
are nearly set will it now bring us back
together
as a country or further break us apart
jason farrell sky news